while talking about adjustments and
lifestyle another big part of your life
has been Brazilian Jujitsu martial arts
and I can generalize yeah and what
people don't know because obviously the
BJJ community or let's say the martial
arts community sometimes people don't
know when we make references so for
example black belt or brown belt people
don't understand what that means so in a
nutshell this is what I understand of it
and you can correct me if I'm wrong so
usually when someone starts Brazilian
jiu-jitsu they start with a white belt
and there are four stripes between each
belt
except for the black belt in which case
there's more stripes but so it takes
about a year for them to get out of that
and into blue belt and then three years
to go usually I mean I don't know if
this is typical of your club but usually
three years to get out blue belt and
then two years to get a purple belt and
then another two years against black
belt so Brazilian jiu-jitsu getting to
purple belt level a lot of you know
people have said that this is kind of
like black belt and most other martial
arts so a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu means you've been doing it for
about ten to twelve years that's what
that's what it means so you yourself are
a black belt with three four stripes now
you're in the fourth 909 so that means
to say that if there are seven stripes
you're gonna be eligible for a red belt
isn't isn't that correct or a red black
and then is it red black and then you go
on to the right okay so I mean I've only
seen maybe one or two people in the
world that have had that on YouTube
you've been doing this for a long time
this is that is the moral of the story
here let me ask you a question with all
that knowledge that you've accumulated
with Brazilian jiu-jitsu experience if
you had half an hour to teach someone
the most important self-defense
techniques obviously we can't
demonstrate it now I know you've done a
video for us it's a hobby which you can
find on your channel the danger yes and
obviously guys if you haven't already
subscribed to the Deen show and the Deen
shows are very important channel you
have to subscribe to and go and video
for us as well if you want to see
physical demonstrations but um what
would you teach someone what are the two
or three main things maybe that you
would teach someone nice that just to
like eyes on a basic level to defend
themselves on self-defense level
headlock escape yes bear hug escape yes
this is something that is very common
that's gonna happen get getting a grab
for the choke from behind getting hog
bear hog is when someone grabs you yes
from the back so these kind of
self-defense moves are very key they're
the quintessential moves in Gracie
Brazilian jiu-jitsu these are what I
would focus on and that's what we do
focus on when people come into our
academy your academies in Chicago
Chicago yes so those are the things that
we focus on when you come into core
fundamentals of the art that's the
number one thing so someone who's come
he doesn't oh she doesn't know anything
about the same self-defense or anything
like that you teach them okay these are
the escapes to the image like the most
common attack stop basically done on
people so for somebody said head lock
escape yeah we have escaped what else
yeah and we can we can we can we can
show them they can film us so the
movements that that are someone on the
street because the headlock is where
someone wants to control your your head
yeah so then they can control the rest
of your body because where the head goes
the body goes yes I need to control your
head and you can see this you see so
many so many and then it's even more
dangerous when someone if you don't know
how to escape and also if someone is
just using all their strength you've
actually had situations where someone is
putting on a headlock you turn your head
the wrong way and now you're into it now
you're into a choke and people have been
killed by that Wow
because you're holding the head and now
instead of turning it you don't learn to
turn to the right where you turn in the
wrong way and now the person now you now
it's right across the neck and now he's
holding even tighter and now all you
need is a few seconds then you go
unconscious then you go brain-dead and
then you're just that's it I'm dead so
these are very detrimental these are the
key fundamental quintessential moves of
Gracie persons yeah we then show them
absolutely in terms of you were telling
me before as well like interview on
development your own kind of like
psychological development where you
started off doing kickboxing striking
and so you weren't just focused on
Brazilian you
you start off doing kickboxing
extracting all these things and and you
were telling me that the the kind of
focus was different like when you going
in there was a feeling of let's get
these like knock out we want to get a
knock out we want to you know but then
obviously as you grow older you start to
mature you're thinking and now you don't
have much to prove now I mean obviously
you've accomplished x y&z so what kind
of advice would you give to someone
who's just starting up martial arts and
maybe has that attitude of you know I'm
the best I need to to prove myself and
all the rest of it that's the beautiful
thing like you got to experience it's a
humbling experience yes when you start
training jiu-jitsu how many people get
all that stress out they come in and no
matter how big you are strong you are
you know if you're not technically sound
yes and then you end up just burning
yourself out because it doesn't matter
if you are a car that has so much 200
300 400 horsepower if you have no gas
things over here it's over so people
come in and that's why you know we go
through we demonstrate some moves and we
ask people for instance a common move is
the mount that's when someone's on top
you imagine someone coming into your
house and now they put you in a position
where they're on top of you and now you
have to try to protect your family how
are you going to protect you forever you
can't even get up how vulnerable you are
and then you see how effective it is
with one simple technique that you're
able to escape but how vulnerable you
are if you don't well so that's that's a
real eye-opener it's and then it really
humbles the the the for the amount
escape it's like a table that has for
instance four legs so you cut off two of
the legs and then what you call is the
umpa and then you you bridge out and you
escape simple technique but now if you
don't know it now you're in a jam in a
real Jam so it humbles the the biggest
biggest of them just like hoist Gracie
oh yes yeah one of my first teachers
where he actually the earlier UFC's 170
pounds and he just defeated everybody
some people like the most collegiate of
wrestlers someone who already knew the
ground dance seven for instance he had
to just wear him down and it took it's
like planes
as an example that's given that you're
just patiently waiting and you're
waiting and even though I don't play
chess but just to give a metaphor that
now it's not about you can maybe finish
someone quick but maybe someone who's
very strong and these guys in the UFC
they were the masters of their craft
that's that's the one thing they were
the most athletic they had black belts
one guy came in and he's got like I
remember he had they ten different black
belts yes but once he was taken to the
ground they all went out the window Wow
right but if you're if you're versed on
the ground and on the top but then you
you incorporate the ground now it's your
your holistic as we call it just like we
talked about now being holistic in your
life and spiritually physically mentally
so now you're complete as a whole as a
martial artist one thing that is
happening nowadays is I'm not sure if
it's as bad in the United in Chicago
area obviously Isis has different areas
it's difficult to generalize but where
you're living in Chicago etc but in the
UK and in London and etc there has been
a rise in anti-islamic rhetoric
obviously that means that people are
being attacked and usually it's the
vulnerables so it's usually women and
children you know people that obviously
you're aware of the layest bullying
incident that happened and so on so in
terms of vulnerable people people that
are less strong let's say for example a
woman if a woman wanted general advice
as to how to defend herself against a
bigger and stronger opponent what would
be the kind of top three things or top
five things you say to her usually with
a woman obviously you have to take this
into consideration that she's much more
she's much weaker than a man yes so she
doesn't want to even if she knows the
technique she don't want to sit there
waiting to submit the guy and you know
just staying a long confrontation but
you you learn enough to have confidence
yeah you learn enough to defend yourself
where you can engage but really look to
disengage and get out yes of the
situation as quickly as possible for
instance what's going to happen is
usually the person is going to and we
can demonstrate this earlier he's gonna
grab the wrist for instance right and
now instead of expending a lot of energy
trying to just pull and get away get
tired and
he grabs you of two hands you learn some
sync simple but effective techniques how
you can go ahead and free yourself
without exerting too much energy and now
you can run or the people grabs you the
guy wants to you know grab you that's
that beer hut front bear hug
now she learns how to go ahead and make
the frame make the distance put a knee
in and now she's out she's out of there
and then other things that are very
important just watching your environment
where you're walking right this is the
beautiful thing about our Dean that you
know it encourages you to have a
bodyguard all the time we call them you
know yeah and people don't understand
that this is because of the love and
reverence that we have for our womenfolk
I mean that we there's usually you know
we're traveling and all these things but
if obviously if she's by herself that
she's gonna be she can't have all the
time and that but you learn these simple
yet effective techniques that you can
apply them and imagine if you don't if
you don't have the techniques I mean
with the techniques obviously your
chances to defend yourself and to escape
are much higher dramatically yeah I mean
that's one thing I've because if a woman
comes into a for example work
compensation of striking with a man and
he's a strike up she's got much less
chance if she goes into a conversation
of like let's take pure wrestling and
he's a wrestler that she got but BJJ is
it's much more to do with technical
reality isn't it so it gives a woman
much more chance than almost any other
that's how I'm thinking about you agree
with that all yeah yeah absolutely a
hundred percent I